that job that you guys had was a real
um organizer like that job was so
inflexible the schedule and it dictated
so much where you live how often you can
leave where you live when you get to be
home how much you need to sleep before
you go back to the place where you do
the job like we kind of organized our
whole life around the demands of that
job
um and that changed really recently so
we're still kind of I think sorting
through what is possible now yeah you
don't have to be at the studio five days
a week right right and you get more than
you know two weeks off at a time oh yeah
we went on our when we got married it
was one of those that was back in the
NBC days and so that was
um one of those winter breaks like you
guys never got more than two weeks off
at a time and not and only in the
summertime only like in August yes and
which is like when my I took my family
to Japan once right which was good
fantastic trip but going to Japan in
August is like going to Tampa in August
is you know but that's when you have the
time to make it yeah exactly yeah yeah
so we did it um in January and it was a
week-long break and so he had to get we
did it in Seattle so he had to get to
Seattle for the rehearsal dinner the
rehearsal the wedding the whatever and
then we had our honeymoon it's like okay
now you gotta go do that and then check
that box before you get back to New York
to be back on you know on the set so
um I remember the first time that we had
three weeks off in August I mean Conan
used to say like I wonder what it's like
to have three weeks off I wonder what
it's like which is by the way like join
the rest of the population yeah
well and also I mean my feelings during
the year yeah my feeling with him
sometimes is like I bet you could swing
it if you pushed it considering your
names in the goddamn title well for many
years I think that was not the case it
probably it did turn into that but um
but yeah that was that was uh anyway so
we were still living under those
constraints but then also like little
kids and all that stuff so I'm sort of
like trying to Cobble together my own
homegrown MFA and theater and and
um which probably maybe I learned more
doing that way I don't know because yeah
I really was had to be active about it
um so yeah that's what I've been do it
but you know the theater it's I don't
know if it's how it compares to
TV or film in terms of how long it takes
a person average to emerge yeah but it
seems like it takes an average of a
decade for someone who's working
constantly
um sometimes there are exceptions to
that obviously like you know and
certainly historically there have been a
bunch of exceptions to that but but it
really takes a long time yeah for
someone to gain any kind of traction and
break through yeah even just in that
industry forget like the public so yeah
so I'm I've been in emerging play right
now for quite some time whether or not
I'll actually
emerge yeah I don't know but it's been
fun trying yeah I see that would be I
just don't have the patience the
patience and the attention span it's in
a way when I've written pilots and then
get notes in back by the time it's time
to really then for the pilot to be
passed on and sold to somebody I'm done
with it yeah right I'm no longer even
interested in it because they've just
kind of needled you to death on it and I
just you know and then I end up getting
be like
you know if there's too many notes I'm
like fine screw it never you know I yeah
whatever I don't even care anymore I'll
show you right yeah way to go Andy you
really showed them by not caring about
your own project I had a friend who used
to say oh show me yeah that's yeah but
so that daily that daily product really
does have its upsides of what you guys
did oh absolutely couldn't you say we're
we're making pictures in the sand yes
and that that to me is terrifying
because it takes me so long to figure
out what I'm doing and to get it to the
place where I'm happy with it that I
need it to be a little bit more
indelible I need it to feel like maybe
someone will perform this more than one
time that this will have a life in a
different age yeah maybe don't know if
any of it will but yeah I try you get I
mean again I I don't know I mean I guess
it's kind of suited to my personality
like when I started working freelance I
liked the
different faces different places aspect
of it
um and so that's why you know like being
on One show for all of those years was
not something I would have chosen or
well
yeah probably chosen but also just like
I wouldn't have pictured that for myself
and like my the metaphor I always use is
we're laying tracks for a train that you
can hear coming like it's it's like just
over that hill we better get these
tracks laid we can't overthink it yeah
which is it which is kind of a blessing
in that sense and and coming back to
work on The Tonight Show uh
with Conan was you know I had you know I
left in 2000 and I had a very kind of
like I gotta go out into the world and
see what I can do on my own because you
know I mean
one of the remarkable things about the
two of us working together is that it's
very difficult for people with similar
skill sets to sit next to each other and
do the thing that they do differently
yeah differently and you know like a
concert yeah in concert especially like
you know it's like having two lead
singers yeah you know it just it it's
Anna Nancy Wilson although one of them
does play the guitar right exactly yeah
yeah Ellen he plays a guitar but he's
also like the lead singer so but but you
know I mean it's it's remarkable that we
got through that but that's also too
like I think I needed to go away and do
some other stuff and but the main thing
when I came back it was like
I can think of something in the morning
and it'll be on TV that night that's
pretty incredible it's crazy yeah nobody
gets that I mean such a small percentage
of people get that and you know and it
might not matter to you like if you're
if you're
I'm an overthinker yeah so for me it's
like terrifying right and I'm thinking
too of like now anyone listening to this
who's you know dealing in YouTube at all
is like why wait till tonight yes it's
just now it's just happening as it's
happening absolutely which terrifies me
I can't even tell you yeah yeah well
then I'm just that I don't
I'm just too old to I still am living in
an analog kind of that just the
structural nature of television and
entertainment to me is is just
Antiquated right
um because
I you know somebody somebody that's like
far more successful than me is on
YouTube and I'll hear oh they're on
YouTube like oh oh gosh a small time but
it's like no dummy there that's the
mainstream that's what's happening at
the big time yeah yeah it's it's it's
our Tick Tock really right I know I I
can't even keep trying I know and well
and there's there's so many things
that that I'm just like how do you make
money at that where does the money come
from I mean podcasts for that matter
terrifying like you know when
people sell podcasts for gazillions of
dollars I mean how does that how does
that happen has anyone checked Tomatoes
is it really like is there really that
much money
yeah yeah again but I mean but it's like
are they selling that many socks
okay okay I trust I trust that it's
something there